I know my name is Malcolm Goodwin and
I'm fe new couch and we're happy for the
freelancers relaxers he freelances
really tell us what it's about 50 a
freelancer stars could be send Robert De
Niro Forest Whitaker directed by
distance herero and it's pretty much
about three friends from making dreams
who joined the police force and they're
lured into the to the dark side of the
force that sounds like Star Wars when I
said that but it's not stalled for
exactly like it's been with is of the
believe yours in New York City yeah
that's exactly like oh yeah empire
strikes back okay the dark side of the
point with it my next film is about
Empire Strikes Back no something else
but I'm just letting the cat out the bag
now yeah yeah that was your Pacino so
this all looks very glamorous you're on
the red carpet at Holly shorts but
really how much work is is that you put
in behind the scenes to get to this
point because everybody thinks it's so
easy and it looks fun I gotta tell you
it wasn't easy I mean it took me eight
days to write the script and then
another 14 to get
yeah Chris knees and many were close but
it's all worth it nothing the red carpet
but just some satisfaction of being a
movie lover I like to go to the movies
get popcorn sit there and be haha I
didn't it better and then leave and
nothing was different on my premiere
Sandra popcorn laughs a chuckle a jump
and when I left I thought isn't it
better so
that's the point you make movies so you
can inspire yourself and have to go
around you and that's really that's
really it and keep doing it effectively
want to do it was it to the top
camera
I've been acting since I was 14 years
old you know and it wasn't I was
doing it so much you know
yawn and
internship at film studio understand
what hackle goes on behind the camera I
mean decision that
I don't want to act in front of the
camera because at that point
one ninety percent of my life since I
made the change the jump you know I
spent a lot of work I know surround
yourself with the right Keith Green the
right team trying to figure out the
right path
bye pass on your back finding your way
so you know to your goals
you know it's a lot of
you know its initial learning process
where you have to remain
focus
to yourself and use that same look I use
that same love them that I have an out
make money from this things like that
but just always they connected to what
got me into it
it's probably more than a couple
hours I'm not
they're never banking hours
if I did
listen
oh my dog
this act
ok
of the business
I was I was a grip
all day because i found a lot tougher
more selfless man
but I do feel like
New Year's doesn't show I find it goes
it's waiting to see a movie the best
looking at film you soon for 2012 my
favorite movie
this year
independent board Oh independent sorry I
didn't hear that I don't go see the baby
okay you know what's crazy is as much as
I love film I'm so busy I mean yeah I
even find time I can tell you when I
will fulfill that would like to see Leo
Viola days one that stars need a girl to
do the phone 1 p-7 so much I want to see
that you want to see that I've had that
on my list
there was something else I can see but
I'm not remember
but that's number one on my independent
witness